.
>>> PENTAGON PRESS SECRETARY
JOHN KIRBY IS GOING TO BE
JOINING US SHORTLY.
>>> WE DO HAVE BREAKING NEWS, WE
JUST SHOWED YOU DEVASTATING
PICTURES FROM THE CITY OF
MYKOLAYIV.
THIS IS IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
WE SAW A MUNICIPAL BUILDING
THERE, HALF OF IT JUST DESTROYED
BY A RELENTLESS RUSSIAN AIR
ATTACK.
WE JUST GOT WORD THAT THREE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN THAT
ATTACK.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY THREE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED.
18 MORE PULLED FROM THE RUBBLE,
INJURED, NOW IN THE HOSPITAL.
THE ATTACK ON THE BUILDING IN
MYKOLAYIV, DEADLY.
WE'LL HAVE MUCH MORE ON THAT FOR
YOU AS INFORMATION COMES IN.
>>> A CITY 90 MILES NORTHEAST OF
KYIV HAS SEEN RELENTLESS
SHELLING SINCE RUSSIA INVADED
THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE THIS VIDEO WE'RE SHOWING
YOU OF THE EXTENSIVE DAMAGE TO
THE CITY.
THE MAYOR OF CHERNIHIV, HE'S
DRIVING DOWN THE ROADS HERE.
HE JOINED ME EARLIER TODAY.
HERE'S THAT CONVERSATION.
MR. MAYOR, I SEE WHERE YOU'RE
STANDING AND IT'S JUST
DESTROYED.
TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR
CITY.
>> Translator: OUR CITY HAS BEEN
UNDER ATTACK FROM SHELLS AND AIR
STRIKES FOR MORE THAN A MONTH.
WHERE I'M STANDING NOW, THIS IS
THE SITE WHERE A CRUISE MISSILE
HAS STRUCK.
THE DIRECTION OF THIS MISSILE
WAS FROM BELARUS.
IT CAME FROM BELARUS.
AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE THE
LOCATION IS SUCH THAT IT -- IT
COULDN'T HAVE COME ANYWHERE
ELSE -- FROM ANYWHERE ELSE.
THIS IS THE SITE OF THE CINEMA
AND SO WE CAN SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THE RUSSIAN ARMY
IS WAGING THIS WAR NOT AGAINST
THE ARMED FORCES OF UKRAINE BUT
AGAINST CIVILIANS.
STRIKING AGAINST CIVILIANS AND
THEY'VE BEEN UNDER -- OUR CITY
HAS BEEN UNDER SUSTAINED ATTACK
FROM MORTAR SHELLS AND FROM
MORTAR SHELLING AND AIR STRIKES.
THE MORTARS ARE STRIKING FROM A
LONG DISTANCE AND THE SHELLS ARE
120 MILLIMETERS.
SO WE CAN SAY THAT THESE ARE NOT
HIGH-PRECISION WEAPONS AND
THEY'RE STRIKING ON CIVILIAN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE HAVE ENOUGH PROOF SO WE CAN
SAY THAT THIS IS FASCISM AND
GENOCIDE.
WE HAVE -- IN THE LAST THREE
WEEKS, WE LOST 350 PEOPLE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE ARE
CIVILIANS.
YESTERDAY OVERNIGHT WE'VE HAD AN
ATTACK ON OUR RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS, AND WE HAVE
CURRENTLY TWO HOSPITALS WHICH
ARE FULL OF CASUALTIES.
WE'VE HAD 400 PEOPLE IN HOSPITAL
NOW AND OVER THE LAST DAY, 30
PEOPLE WENT INTO HOSPITAL.
THAT'S THE INTENSITY OF THE
ATTACKS.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
ARE CIVILIANS.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE LEFT
LIVING IN THE CITY AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE TOTAL HAVE BEEN KILLED?
>> Translator: SO BEFORE THE WAR
WE HAD 290,000 PEOPLE LIVING IN
HERE.
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
DIED OF THESE ATTACKS, WE
ESTIMATE THIS AT ABOUT 350.
IT'S SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 300 AND
400.
WE DON'T HAVE THE EXACT FIGURES,
AND THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT
WE CAN ONLY COUNT PEOPLE WHO
DIED IN HOSPITAL.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DIE AS SOON
AS THE BOMB STRIKES AND SO
IT'S -- YOU KNOW, THERE'S AN
EXPLOSION AND THE PEOPLE ARE
GONE.
WE CANNOT IDENTIFY THEM.
WE CANNOT STATE LEGALLY THAT
THEY'RE DEAD.
SO THEY -- THEY'RE NOT COUNTED
EITHER AMONG THE LIVING OR AMONG
THE DEAD.
AND ALSO PEOPLE WHO GET INTO --
STRAIGHT INTO MORTUARIES, THOSE
PEOPLE ARE COUNTED BY THE ARMED
FORCES AND THE PROSECUTOR'S
OFFICE.
SO WE ESTIMATE AN NUMBER BETWEEN
300 AND 400.
BUT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
DIED.
>> DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH FOOD,
HUMANITARIAN SUPPLIES?
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK YOU CAN
HOLD OUT?
>> Translator: WE WILL
DEFINITELY SURVIVE.
WE WILL HOLD ON FOR AS LONG AS
NECESSARY UNTIL OUR VICTORY.
WE WILL DEFINITELY SURVIVE AND
WE SHALL NOT SURRENDER.
WE WILL PUSH THE OCCUPIERS AWAY.
>> MR. MAYOR, WHAT WAS THAT?
>> Translator: YOU HAVE JUST
HEARD AN EXPLOSION.
THAT MEANS SOMETHING HAS FLOWN
IN TO ATTACK US.
YOU CAN GIVE THIS RECORDING TO
YOUR MILITARY AND THEY WILL TELL
YOU THAT THIS IS NOT OUR
EXPLOSION.
THIS ISN'T US STRIKING
SOMETHING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS COME
FROM THE ENEMY SIDE.
>> MR. MAYOR, ARE YOU SAFE RIGHT
NOW?
>> Translator: ABSOLUTELY
NOWHERE IS SAFE IN THE CITY NOW
BECAUSE THE CITY IS UNDER ATTACK
FROM THE ENEMY, AND THE ENEMY IS
STRIKING EVERYWHERE.
ABSOLUTELY EVERYWHERE.
THIS IS NOT HIGH-PRECISION
STRIKES.
THESE ARE BLANKET FIRE AND IT IS
DELIBERATELY AIMED AT THE
CIVILIAN POPULATION.
THEY ARE EXTERMINATING
CIVILIANS.
>> MR. MAYOR, I MET A BOY, A
15-YEAR-OLD BOY WHO WAS FORCED
FROM HIS HOME IN CHERNIHIV AT
GUNPOINT -- GO AHEAD.
>> Tra
>> I'M SORRY.
ONE MINUTE ATTENTION, PLEASE.
>> Translator: I CAN GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE RECENTLY OF A SHELL
STRUCK A LINE FOR BREAD.
IT WAS A BREAD LINE.
PEOPLE STANDING IN LINE TO BUY
BREAD AND 14 PEOPLE DIED
IMMEDIATELY AND 18 PEOPLE WERE
INJURED.
>> MR. MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
WE HOPE HELP GETS TO YOUR CITY
SOON.
PLEASE STAY AS SAFE AS YOU CAN,
THANK YOU.